[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right let's go what's going on you
guys uh go and talk real quick bg so i
can make sure they can hear you
test test check check yeah there we go
so
what's going on you guys it's addict
here with the addicts
show it's been a while since i did these
i canceled it last
week for uh you know scheduling your
reasons but today
i'm here with with bg we're gonna be
talking about e3
and more particularly microsoft's e3 i
know that you probably have a couple
uh set of thought process behind what
happened at e3 but
you know first off bg how did you feel
about e3 in general
um a3 overall it's definitely like
pretty disappointing
i can't even say disappointing let me
just say it i think it was
overall bad because i didn't expect much
you know i didn't really i didn't really
know what a lot of people were
showing because like everything
everything like you might have guessed
everybody was like yeah don't expect
this don't expect that so i was like i'm
just not gonna expect anything so i
wasn't disappointed but yeah overall i
think it was kind of bad
yeah i felt like besides
microsoft everyone was kind of like
lackluster
like i don't know what i don't know how
how many years do we gotta go before
people realize
this is how you do a conference like
think about how many years has went by
and people still don't understand how to
do conferences
yeah and i guess i we should uh give a
little bit of a
you know grace because of covid and
i guess that's what every that's what
everybody says you know oh because of
covet it slowed everything down
and everything like that um so maybe a
lot of these
uh publishers they might have a little
bit more to show
if there was no colvin and i think
that's possible but i don't like to give
covert too much credit i think it's it i
think
the thing is is people
people have this weird concept when it
comes to
look over definitely affects everything
it does
and especially these events the problem
with these events
is when studios aren't running at 100
they have to do they they have to make
sacrifices and one of the sacrifices
they have to make with this
is like look do we delay our game to
take resources away from the game to
make these or do we continue going
through with what we're going through
like and you know i think that's why
you saw a lot of cgi is because
they they don't have the ability to make
these
to this to the degree that they used to
make them
so you know i feel like that that's one
of the biggest issues that you're going
to see is you're going to see a lot of
aspects
that you wouldn't normally see and
that's because of covid because they're
not
able up until recently a lot of these
people weren't even going to the studio
like
they're going to the studio more than
they used to i got a piece of cheese in
my beard
well not that you yes man yeah
but you know that's what i think's going
on
is i think you're seeing more of an
aspect of
they had to make sacrifices neither
extend
the duration because let's see let's be
real a lot of these games are already
delayed enough
i don't think microsoft's willing to
delay even more and so
square enix and not to mention some of
these games look really rough
like not even microsoft square enix
looks so bad i don't know what was going
on with that oh yeah
that guardians of the galaxy all the
games looked bad
i don't know what was going on over
there marvel need to stop giving uh
square enix marble properties like i
don't know what y'all doing giving them
all these properties it's terrible
maybe it's they must be handed in the
bag
like a big bag because i just don't see
why they can't
how does disney keep messing up who to
give these you could literally do a
google search to figure out who's doing
better games you know what i'm saying
like
yeah i mean because because insomniac
set the bar really high with spider-man
so like anything else you know next to
it looks kind of mediocre
yeah so you know this e3 i feel like the
miracle e3 because
it probably wasn't supposed to happen i
mean if you if you got accepted to media
there wasn't
huge advice to being there so you know i
got to give them a little bit of
a little bit of a pass like overall
everyone because of this covet thing
because
i know for a fact that people had to
make some decisions with this covert
thing
you know and i think the reason that you
see a lot of gameplay from games like um
forza horizon it's because that game the
game's done pretty much
like i don't know if you saw kofi said
you could pre-load the whole game right
now on steam
or wherever it is so that was definitely
done
yeah so they're probably just they're
they're just doing uh
maintenance and stuff trying to make
sure it comes out in the best
possible shape it is so i feel like
that's the reason you sought more from
them is because the majority
the majority of the game's done so now
it was easier for them to dedicate
probably 20 30 people to make these but
i mean you look at
halo halos they didn't give no release
dates so that's probably full from the
air if that's done
so do you take the you know the amount
of people
required to make this what it's supposed
to or do you continue
letting them do what they need to and do
the bare minimum
bare minimum sounds bad but that's what
it really was like let's
let's do what we have to to get these
out and to keep people
happy but still keep our roadmap going
if that makes sense
so i mean somebody showed some of these
shows it would have been better if they
didn't do one at all like people would
have been happier
without these because you didn't really
you didn't give them
anything a lot of these just could have
been trailers you could have sent some
of these trailers to ign or gamespot and
it probably would have been
better that way because you know people
cert expect a certain
you expect a certain type of
announcement at e3 these are just
send it to gamespot send it to ign and
everybody else let them upload it to
youtube
you know do that that that final fantasy
game made by team ninja
that that was that was rough like i got
a demo right
yeah that didn't work for two days yeah
i don't know i don't think i've ever
seen a demo
like launch broken that's an that's that
might be a new one
i don't know if it was something like on
on sony side or something on their side
but whatever it was man
like don't these things have like a
certification process like
how do you go through that not work
yeah i don't know man that's that's
definitely crazy
but it and then the game itself i'm like
it looks
it looks really rough like it looked
rough and it looked stupid too
i'm like i i understand you know the
the crossover oh you know it's team
ninja's take on a final fantasy game and
you know they're real good with combat
uh it looks forced
yeah but i played a little bit of it
it's not bad i do think like
visually because team ninjas games like
neo
i thought they look good like for what
it was you know but
that game that game looked rough man
it looked rough and then they had like
that chaos fight the end with a chaos
question mark
i'm like what is that even supposed to
mean
like and what's funny is when i heard
that i was so excited but then when i
played it
i was like let me let me bring that down
a couple let me bring it down a couple
yeah so well how you watch the uh
you watch the whole e3 show on microsoft
apparently what what what first off
what was your expectations going into
that
uh so i mean you know i saw everybody
saying
everybody that apparently had some at
least a little bit of uh knowledge
saying you know don't expect to vow
don't expect no indiana jones don't
expect no wolfenstein
no fable don't expect a whole a whole
lot of stuff
right so i know everything that we we
shouldn't see
um all right cool so then that goes to
okay are we at least gonna get game play
for the
apparent few things we are gonna see and
the show is 90 minutes
i'm like are they i don't think they're
going to be able to fill up 90 minutes
of like really relevant
things so some of that is going to be
filling some of part of it is at least
going to be be filler i feel like but at
least if
i felt like there was like 15 minutes of
filler i don't feel like there was a lot
of filler though
i i feel like the majority of the show
was the bulk of
of you know triple a stuff like
battlefield
yeah if you if you pace it out right
even if you have like a good amount of
filler even if you if you pace it out
right it doesn't seem like it and i
think they did pace it out
but what they did show i thought it was
i thought it was like
gonna start out i thought it was gonna
be ruined because you know the starfield
uh
video leaked and and the and the leak
was really and the leak itself was bad
it wasn't even a
good leak like because there wasn't
really any gameplay it didn't tell us
anything about the game so i'm like
listen y'all honestly i think y'all
should have just not showed this
it didn't tell us anything that we
didn't know about the game before
yeah i don't and what's funny is i got
attacked by uh everyone because like
i i'm sorry i expected more from
starfield
i did i expected you know not
necessarily
let's just be real here bg the thing was
announced in 2018
i find it that me expecting to see what
this game's about in 2021
isn't much to ask for it's like people's
like attic you got to be realistic
the games was announced like a decade
ago it feels like
for me to want to know what it's about i
don't feel like a huge thing not being
realistic
yeah and the thing is like it cinematic
cgi trailers can still be good
if you do if if you show in in those
cinematics
what exactly it is the things you would
do in the game for example like that red
fall game we didn't see any gameplay
but the the trailer showed you
like the character's power so you at
least know what the character's powers
are gonna be
you know who the enemy is in the game
you know the type of game it
is just from the trailer and you don't
you haven't seen any gameplay
star field didn't show us anything we
didn't already know
and that was the game takes place in
space okay we are we already knew that
but um i i would say that starfield you
know started out the show badly but it
actually
it picked up from there halo was was
great
um you know it that multiplayer looks
great especially since they released
more gameplay than
the day after which was today or
yesterday i got back
i think it was yesterday okay so that
gameplay you know that expanded gameplay
looked great
um they didn't really show that much of
the single player they they focus on the
multiplayer but the multiplayer looks
great
single player looks you know visually
looks improved because that was the
biggest criticism when we first saw it
and uh um yeah so halo was good
i love battlefield so uh even though you
know that's a multi-plat of course that
i still give them some points because
you know they
they got the first game play and it
looked really good and i love
battlefield
um forza i'm not even i'm not into
racing games at all
everybody knows this but forza is one of
those games
even though i won't play it i want to
play it just because it looks that good
like i want to just drive around
i don't i don't like the gameplay but
that game looks so good i would just
drive around
pointlessly just to look at stuff like
that and that might be the best looking
game like
like that's coming in the near future
like if some of that stuff was looking
photo realistic
yeah and we got to keep in mind like
youtube does decompress it to a certain
point too
so yeah it's probably going to look even
better than
it looked there so i got a list of
everything there man so
obviously they opened up with starfield
i i i'm with you man i i feel like
look if if you're not gonna show
anything relevant why even have it i
we i think we all know why this was here
that they wanted to say look this is
this is exclusive that that's what they
wanted to say
uh and for the most part i i feel like
to a point maybe they needed to do that
but i don't think they needed to show
starfield they could like um
the game they ended with it i can't
remember what that red fall or whatever
it's called yeah it was red fall yeah
the
red fall they could have just said red
fall and star filter exclusive and they
didn't have to bring starfield into this
uh but you know and people told me what
what do you think okay
let me let me ask you a question on the
promotion for this get for this event
on the lower left is clearly referencing
starfield true or false
wait wait wait wait where exactly are
you talking about the trailer no the
promotion for the the event when they
did that picture
that had like the spartans on the top
right and starfield was on the bottom
left
that like the promotion for the event oh
yeah yeah so so to me i'm looking at
that
i'm like okay this is going to be one of
the the pillars of this event would you
not agree
absolutely yeah and the fact that that
todd howard talked longer than the
actual trailer
i felt like was a problem yeah
i i don't know how how anybody is
defending that that starfield trailer
like i don't i don't know how any
like whether you consider it to be
in-engine cinematic cgi whatever it is
it was pointless we learned nothing i
think people forgot
trailers are supposed to tell you
something about the game that you don't
know
it's not just about to it's not just
supposed to be a time waster just
just to put something up they have
purposes like people don't get that
yeah i i think a lot of people
here here it is i think a lot of people
that are telling me to keep my
that like telling me that i can't be
hyped for i don't even think a lot of
them are gonna play this game anyway i
bet you
that some of you know these people that
when it comes down to it like you i it's
like how i feel about halo
don't tell me not to be hyped for a game
and like people kept saying add you're
the one that hyped up this game
no i didn't every time that that
microsoft just talked they have talked
about this game
i'm pretty sure when they had that that
that uh that event with
but that's explaining the purchase that
i think they brought
up starfield there too well remember
when they when they did that interview
with todd howard and pete hines
they brought up starfield there too like
i'm just like they put it on the
promotion
why would you expect me not to think
there was going to be not gameplay there
yeah
and and i think uh afterwards i mean
people were already saying like it's
it's either
uh just um fallout or uh
uh elder scroll in in in space skyrim in
space and i think todd howard came out
and said yeah it's pretty much skyrim in
space
um just off that i already know i'm not
i'm not probably i'm probably not gonna
like it because i don't like skyrim i
don't like elder scroll
but yeah i mean if okay that's if that's
what the game is cool but like
you know once again they didn't really
show
anything at all it's like how i feel
like people telling me
how you know one of the biggest things i
hate about
the community and not every community
not even just this community
is like people will sit there and
they'll tell me what's good for halo and
i know they don't play halo like that
you know what i'm saying like
yeah you know nothing about that so why
people like oh
the game needs to change yeah in some
ways it does but the way you're
saying it needs to change it's going to
be a different game it's not going to be
halo
so it's just like yeah like like i
hate what i do hate that when people try
to tell me
you know something about a game that
like you listen you're not you don't
know more about this game than me you're
not a bigger fan of this game
than me like that's why when it comes to
halo like i tell people all the time
like
i i'm not like a halo die hard i've
played every halo i beat every halo
but i'm not like one of those that's
like super into the story i'm into the
multiplayer more than
the story but even the multiplayer like
i
i'm okay with whatever typically
whatever they do with halo like i know
the purist they're like
we don't want this and it shouldn't be
no running there shouldn't be this there
shouldn't be this in a multiplayer
and i leave that up to the experts i'm
like listen y'all over here
halo purist you all of the halo die hard
i'ma let y'all argue about what should
be in the multiplayer i stand over here
mind my business and just play halo yeah
and that's what i feel everybody
else should do just like listen if you
ain't into the game like that don't be
telling
like the die hards and and like the ones
who are really into it
what you know how they should feel about
the game
solomon said it does need to change and
that comes from someone who's played a
lot of halo
look what they showed me is change like
what's funny is these are the same
people that says halo 5 wasn't changed
halo 5 drastically changed taylor
so much that they reverted at all
because they were like yeah maybe we
went a little too far
like they had thrusters in the game like
like to me i feel like they wanted an
rpg or something
like how else do you expect them to
change it like
like there's a difference between
building on the foundation that made
halo halo
and changing it entirely and i feel like
people want it to change entirely
yeah and i think that halo trailer the
multiplayer i think
it was very safe like nothing in there i
mean there was the grappling hooks and i
didn't see too many people complaining
about that there was some new stuff
but i don't think anybody like even the
purists
saw anything that they absolutely hated
because they did focus on
what the core wanted and i and i don't
think this halo is going to
be i think they're going backwards
as far as the core gameplay right and
that's not i don't mean at a bat in a
bad way
but they're just going back to what
people want there's they're servicing
their their core multiplayer multiplayer
dudes and they're not trying to
you know really reinvent or innovate
anything and i'm like
that that's fine i don't you know that's
fine you know it's funny i always make
this joke
um people that played gears five you
know i said this a couple weeks ago it's
like
you're playing gears 5 and then guess
what people said that needed a change
that
that gears needs it's more gears it
needs to be different
so and then the same people that said
gear is five
needs to change it needs to be different
than gears
are the same people that says gears hive
busters
was amazing it was awesome uh bg isn't
give heist busters more like gears than
gears 5 was
absolutely it's more it's more gears
five yeah yeah that's my point it's just
like
yeah gears five needed to change but
give hive busters is where it should
have been
when give hive busters is more like the
original trilogy than gears five
is so i'm just like you you guys are
contradicting yourselves i'm confused
like yeah i mean listen i prefer i think
like there's people i think gears 4 is
better than gears 5 and i think you all
are on drugs i think the direction
i think they need to go further in the
direction that they did with gear
with gears 5. they had very light like
rpg elements
and this like this hub world where you
could explore different parts it wasn't
linear i think they need to like
not go all the way right with that but
push it like
25 percent more in that direction and i
think
like that's what gears should be because
like i understand
come drastically changing the genre is
completely hard renewing it
renewing it you know making it feel new
after three games is it
is extremely hard like i don't know how
if people realize how hard that is so
you know i think they're going in the
right direction with that it's like i
said i've always felt like the reason
that 343 is so hit and miss is because
they constantly care too much about what
people say
like halo 4 i didn't like the
multiplayer i'm glad they listened to it
but one of the reasons they changed it
is because they were listening to the
community
one of the reasons they changed halo 5
is because they were listening to the
community
like like at one point 343's got to put
their foot down but like this is our
game not yours
because i feel like they keep changing
it drastic i mean if you think about it
they have changed halo drastically three
times
they bro like the nasher they they've
changed the way the nasha works in
in gears five at least like four to six
times and i'm like that's
like it's crazy so yeah we'll get back
to
to halo here in a second so stalker 2
was that something that you're
interested in
did that catch because i feel like this
was one of the highlights of the entire
conference so um i mean i don't i never
played any stalker game
um bond tells me that that that game is
very much like uh
arma or uh escape from tarkov you know
one of those uh
realistic sims it looks great the game
the gun play
and the visuals look amazing um but it
it
and it reminds me a lot of metro exodus
and uh just the metro games
um so it looks good i'm not sure if it's
i haven't played a lot of those you know
sims those are you know extremely
realistic uh fps but from what i saw it
looked real good and
impressive you know it was 105 they said
there's 150 gig
download but i would i would try it out
it looked good
i think stalker it's definitely not
something that i don't feel like i
played
i'm not saying i'm not going to try it
i'll probably try it because i'm pretty
sure it's in game pass but it's just
like
like stalker 2 i didn't really it's like
you said i didn't play the other ones
and to me i'm just sitting here like the
whole time they're playing it because it
was literally the second thing they
showed right after star field
i'm just like can we please move on like
they they spent a lot of time on stalker
like an absurd amount of time on stalker
so let's go let's go on to to back for
blood is that something that you're
interested in
so i've never really been into the four
player you know
co-op uh games like oh yeah yeah you're
you're the king of if you need friends
it's not a good game thing
yeah that's you that's usually my stance
if you can't play a game alone and enjoy
it then it's probably not a good game
because it's
it's solely based on because you because
i think you're not really having fun
with the game you're having fun with
your
with your friends and i think those are
i think those are kind of two different
things
um because i was never a fan of left for
dead i thought like
i thought like there's a lot of like
leopard is one of those games when it
came out
and i'm like yo this game is boring as
hell i'm like why is everybody into
this you know i thought i was an alien
or something but yeah i just i like even
like even borderlands like everybody
plays borderlands with friends i play
borderlands alone
and beat those games because i think
it's a better game alone but
but with this back for blood i think it
looks
better than um i mean obviously visually
looks better but gameplay wise
it looks more fun than like past four
player uh co-op games
you know but a lot of these and there's
a there's been a lot announced lately
these four player
co-op games i mean we're just gonna
shoot we just got through with the
extinction
second yeah bro there's like four games
four games like this
coming out there's there's back for
blood there's red fall
there's that aliens game that's a
three-player co-op you know horde
shooter and then
that contraband game i think made being
made by amp avalanche is one and i think
i'm forgetting what so
these these are games that there's a lot
of games like this coming out right now
but
this one um back for blood looks like
something i would i would give a try
even though i'm not
into the the whole shooting a horde
uh in in co-op games well
contraband we're about to talk about
that here in a second so let's go and go
to contraband all right contraband
i i was a little disappointed of how
they showed this because
i felt like okay didn't the game state
was coming out next year
yeah so i'm just like you have nothing
to show like
and i get it's like i go back to the
pandemic thing you know
it's hard to choose especially games
coming out so soon if you're going to
take away from the actual
gameplay but i feel like games that are
coming out next year you need to at
least
have a little splice of gameplay you
don't have to have like a huge amount
but
like clearly it's a gta heist
inspired game that's a co-op and i'm
cool with that
i feel like that would be really good
because i really enjoy i don't like gta
online but i like the heists
i think those are fun and if they want
to do that then i'm
okay with that is that something that
you're interested in like when it comes
out next year are you ever going to try
that
yeah so it says yeah it's a yeah it's a
co-op open world game like so here's the
thing i think these games
because i think these four player or
whatever how many players it is co-op
game
they're perfect for for xbox um and pc
because
because of game pass because typically
you know
like you know of course there's no
barrier for entry so if
before if you wanted like oh let's get
all my friends on this game you
y'all gotta you know shell out that
money um to buy it now with these four
player you know co-op games
everybody could just play pretty much
for nothing so it i think it helps
it just really helps these games and i
think people will play it more for the
reason that you know it has a low
barrier for entry
then they actually want to play a whole
bunch of you know four-player co-op
games but
yeah i'm not in i mean i don't know
anything about contraband so i'm not
really
i don't really have any feelings about
this one pretty much what i've been told
is it takes a lot of similar aspects
from games like uh the gta 5 heist
probably some from payday because i feel
like that would be a little bit
on the same thing yeah i didn't like
payday i mean i'm not like
saying exactly about people yeah but you
know to me
i i'm i'm interested because i really
like the heists
and i think that the heist were good
enough to
have me at least give it a try like
like it kind of had like a like a
a narco feeling too like it looked like
there's a little bit of drugs involved
in that
so yeah i i'm gonna try it out man i'ma
try it out i think that
look people know i'm not a big fan of
just cause i think just cause
it's just trash like i don't like just
calling it's like absolutely
like i don't like games that literally
built around
just blowing [ __ ] up i i think that is
that is so
ridiculous and for some reason people
like that game
i don't just don't understand like every
time i play that game i'm just like
is there something else it's a brain
dead game
and i don't even think it's a brain dead
game because i like games like that like
i can play games like destiny
and just kick it in a party not worry
about what's going on and just
play i get bored from from just cause
so see thieves i don't
know many people that's a fan of this
clearly this is directed more towards a
casual
audience of the people that's probably
making this game where it is now
do you think them doing a pirates of the
caribbean collaboration will
will maybe bring more people back to the
game to try it out again uh
not exactly i mean i think from what i
know it's it's the pc
community that really seems to be into
sea of thieves
there's a lot of people it's it's it's
it's a pretty popular game on
xbox too it's it's always one of the top
play not maybe the
the most play but it's always up there
yeah um
yeah i you know i don't see the fun in
sea of thieves i tried it out when it
first came out
it's not my type of game i don't know if
it'll bring people back
i think it'll just you know give people
who are you know still interested
still playing it just uh more content
but i don't see this like
really moving the needle necessarily and
i'm a big pirate to the caribbean
you know fan i i love all the movies
except
for was kind of mid but all the rest of
them i think they're amazing
yeah and when it comes to it i i feel
like
i'm gonna try because i've always been a
fan of pirates of the caribbean
and i've always wanted to get back into
this game because when i have played it
it's been fun
but it's like you said earlier it's
definitely one of those games you need
friends you can't just go in there and
play this by yourself
you're going to get bored real quick and
it isn't game pass so it makes it it
does make it easier to get friends to
play it
now we're going to talk about
battlefield i'm hyped for this game
i think this is one of the most best
the probably the highest point of the
show to me
because it it showed me like look
it's clearly not an xbox exclusive but
it did
it did show me that you're gonna want
the series x to play this game
on consoles in the best fidelity you
possibly can because first
off you're going to play with less
people and we all know battlefields
better with more people
so like what was highlights with you on
battlefield is
clearly you're getting this because i
know you're a multiplayer hit
oh yeah i bro i already i already bought
the 110
edition um i've listened for as far as
i'm concerned
i've been waiting for this game since
battlefield 3.
so i got no problem shelling out 100 100
for it
because even though i i really liked um
battlefield 1 and battlefield 5
well not battlefield 5. i like
battlefield 1. um
battlefield 5 was wasn't as good uh but
it you know after three they just made a
whole bunch of battlefields that i
didn't exactly
want um because four battlefield four
was just like kind of a mess at launch
and like i think the map design is
terrible
um so yeah i just feel been waiting a
really long time for this game i like i
like the scale of it the the destruction
that we saw
um you know the the the random events
like the tornado
and the and the uh you can customize
your weapons on on the fly
so and it's so good that it's like it's
in the future but not too far in the
future because you know going too far in
the future with multiplayer
completely ruins it so it's it it's
going to be
i just i just really hope the map design
is good because
even even as good as battlefield is the
map design can
ruin ruin the game um so i'm hoping that
they they get that right and
yeah the game just looks beautiful isn't
operation metro supposed to come back in
this
yeah i said that's what i heard which
was such a good that was that was a
great map
is it so he the next thing i have for
you
uh i don't really i i like 12 minutes
but i feel like
we've seen enough of that i don't even
think that dessert like
not that it deserves let me rephrase
that i don't think
it should have been here now i
understand they wanted to to give it a
release date but it's like
this has been a multi probably at least
at least
one more event so it's just like why
bring it up here just to give a release
date
like you could have literally just
announced that on twitter or something
i get it 12 minutes is probably one of
their biggest indies so that's probably
why i got it
but to me it's like i felt like it just
wasted time you know what i'm saying
yeah um excuse me um
yeah honestly i know almost nothing
about this game besides willem dafoe is
in it
like that that's all i like i'm looking
at the gameplay i've looked at the
gameplay
and i really don't have like a good
understanding of what exactly
it is you're doing it is it like it
takes place all in this house and like
things
things it looks like a a home invasion
and you get like i don't know it looks
like three uh
i think in 12 minutes there's scenarios
that happen
and the whole point is to find the
scenario that has you laid through the
12 minutes i think
oh okay i think i don't know like it's
definitely a cool concept and i want to
try it
but when it comes to like the
the content i just felt like
i don't like when people reuse games
it's not their own you know what i'm
saying like
it's just like if you used it before
don't use it again
because to me it's like you're bringing
up something that that we've already
seen multiple times
i mean i didn't mind it being there but
i do see it's like look
we saw this last year i don't i don't
like when they bring up multiple stuff
that's been in previous events
like because then you're gonna have
scenarios where
in two shows you've seen the same
content and pretty much there you saw
the same content
yeah yeah it's not really something i'm
uh exactly into but yeah
so i i don't think you care about the
the fallout stuff do you
the fallout 76 oh
that was new content right yeah i think
it was two expansions
yeah i was surprised they they were
still making content for it
well actually that games actually turned
around like a lot of people
are playing that game now yeah i'm i'm
an i'm an outer worlds fan i think outer
worlds is way better than fallout
out of worlds yeah we're going to talk
about that here in a second actually
hades i didn't play hades on the switch
i doubt you did too are you going to try
this game since it's coming to consoles
uh well i could have technically we
could have always played it i guess i
could always play that because uh
because it was on pc also right oh the
epic game store
yeah i just i didn't know cause remember
hades is a
is a sleeper it was a low-key game for a
long time
people really started learning about
hades
through a little bit throughout word of
mouth but mainly after it won like a
gazillion
uh game of the year awards uh you know a
bunch of awards that
that's when people really knew about it
so i would have played it already but
you know i only learned about it you
know uh recently i guess
but jack is my game share partner and
he's been dying to play the game
and i oh and it was my turn to buy to
buy a game so
uh yeah i just bought hades on uh ps5 so
oh you got away with that
well it was 20 dollars yeah you know you
know i had to
it's like okay okay i i i i'll call dibs
on this
i'll buy the two exactly i can see that
all right so the next game's halo
infinite
now we've already went into the
multiplayer a little bit uh kid smooth
people like kiss me they're very upset
that there wasn't more campaign which i
told the man like multiple times
they're not showing campaign really i
even said it on weapon wheel
and he still expected it on the show
like
like i get it to me they already showed
that last year and i felt like
the criticism on campaign was the
graphics and how the game looks
so like i don't see a whole lot of
difference between showing what it looks
like in the multiplayer show it looks
like in the campaign
now if they showed it i wouldn't have
been mad but
i didn't expect it because i knew that
this year was going to be revolved
around multiplayer
because to me re-showing some of the
campaign they've already shown
is going to take away from showing
what's on the multiplayer and like i
would have preferred
probably even deep dive more of a deep
dive in the multiplayer
like that uh the overview they showed
yesterday then maybe that should
have been in the actual event but that
was long that was like like 10 minutes
long i don't know if they could have
done that
but i personally felt like what they
showed on halo
was good enough to breathe life into the
into the game
maybe not necessarily correct the [ __ ]
because i feel like
we still need to see the campaign but i
don't necessarily think it had to be
this event
yeah i think the multiplayer showing was
so
was good enough that it kinda uh
compensated for the lack of a single
player that was shown
um so people were like you know like
halo's back you know it looks good the
multiplayer looks good so
it kind of got the single player out of
out of your mind a little bit
and um like listen joseph stayton and
like the rest of them dudes they're not
miracle workers
so what you saw in the single player the
first time they showed the game
it's not going to be drastically
different like they're going to clean it
up
they're going to clean it up it's going
to look very optimized and
and clean but in a year they they can't
create an entirely different game so
it's going to be what you saw
except very much you know pristine and
cleaned up and shaped up
so that's pretty much what what you
should you know expect from the single
player
um like i said i'm not like somebody
who has a microscope on the halo story
so uh you know i'll leave that up to uh
i guess the experts to judge how the
story
is and how it's going to go the story is
kind of weird now like
they put the this this ai out of nowhere
so like my biggest thing is like why
hasn't she been in
any form of of content before this
happened like
i don't know it was kind of weird like
it kind of made me feel like there was a
story restructure
because we the first couple things we
saw in this game was drastically about
you know the relationship between master
chief in this
in in that that pilot and then we get
this event and he's talking to a.i
like and i what and and what cortana is
she said cortana's just deleted now is
that what you said
i i have no clue like the last time i
checked cortana was going crazy
so i'm kind of curious how they just got
him up out of there
her up out of there i don't know i don't
even know
right now i got to see more on the story
and how they're going to unfold the
story
but right now i feel like we've seen
enough to
be like yo this is good enough let's
move on and we'll come back to this
later
keep in mind i know people don't like
the inside xboxes
i feel like the inside xbox is going to
be different down the line
when these studios start making more
games and instead of seeing like
like really bad cringy indie stuff at
these events
you're gonna start seeing more breakdown
of the gameplay of their games
like with the outer worlds twos ready to
be shown in gameplay you're gonna see
that
probably a little bit more of the
campaign and then you're going to be
seeing more of stuff
in it such as what's what i'm looking
for fable gameplay
a valid game play like i think you're
going to see start
start to see more of that at these
events
sorry my voice is going out for some
reason so we got a two dollar super chat
from gerald mack
all held the iop lord addict salute i
appreciate that man i appreciate that
so when we're going off of diablo ii
are you a diablo fan because i'm not
really a diablo fan but i understand
that this game has a
a huge following cult how do you feel
about the
diablo franchise you got any experience
in them uh
not not diablo specifically i've played
it's funny i've played
a bunch of like diablo like games but i
haven't played diablo which they say is
the best one
in this genre i've only played other uh
you know other uh games that
took the uh the gameplay style so no i
haven't played diablo at all
yeah i think i like i do like the
gameplay though
yeah i think that um what i saw looked
interesting
and what i've been told is that that's
the best diablo that that's in the
franchise i don't know
i don't play diablo like that so you
know that was probably a good move i i
would say that's a good move that was
that was one of the games that's not in
game pass
so it's kind of interesting um did you
play plex tale
no i did not so i think we could
probably skip that
but you know it is interesting how
that's in game pass
and the first one was actually
successful so it's kind of
cool to see you know them being
progressive on these popular indies and
making sure that sequel
isn't game past day and date yeah yeah
i agree um i mean i've heard good things
about the single about the uh the story
it's very story driven
and this is good and all that but uh you
know
i'm not really you know i don't think
the you know i need a little bit of good
gameplay with my story so
yeah i know how you are with that we
ain't going to talk about that
so far cry 6. you're not a far cry fan
are you
i i think i've seen you multiple times
uh slander far cry
i'm not a fan of far cry because only i
like far cry like far cry 3 was great
i'll even say far far cry 2 was it was
good i beat
but like after that i couldn't stomach
any more far cry games because
they were literally all all the same and
like
with with very marginal and minor
changes
and it just felt it just it's just it
just you know playing one of playing
those games
after four just like i don't know it
gave me a sick feeling in my stomach it
was just so
dry and just boring and just yeah i
can't i can't even stomach those games
anymore man i don't know
what it is but the game's literally
making me sick and like
yeah i'm it's just so formulaic it's
extremely formulaic
at this point there's they're just like
okay let's let's create a new
you know really interesting villain
because they they use the
the great villains in their game as a
crutch so okay we create the great
villain
and like we don't have to do that much
in any other you know any other pillars
of the game
i can't let you get off on that man i
feel like the gameplay of far cry has
always been solid maybe like the
greatest but it's always been solid
yeah the gameplay is not bad but it's
just it feels very much
the same that's the bro and you know
what it is
if it was only only far cry
that felt like that it wouldn't be as
much of a problem but as
when you play every ubisoft game you
feel like you're playing
every ubisoft game like i i
okay you play far cry you kind of feel
like you're playing assassin's creed you
kind of feel like you're playing watch
dogs
it feels like all of these games are in
the exact same universe
and that makes you fatigued and tired of
playing all of them
you know i think this is bg you know i
think this is
i think this isn't a this is in a third
person
over the shoulder games so you don't
really resonate with it
man you've been very vocal about
first-person games you've been very
vocal about story-oriented
first-person games you can't get away
from that bg we know what's going on
i mean i mean the truth is third person
is is like 99.9
usually better that's just that's just
fact but there are some
like games in first person uh that i
that i
do enjoy even though third person is
usually always better and i i think
i saw some i saw this somewhere don't i
don't know if it's absolutely true
but i think uh they did say far cry 6 is
actually going to have a third person
mode
um but games that have both modes are
usual you usually one ends up being
really bad
but far cry is just you know it's it's
it's not as good as it was man
i just i personally feel like far cry as
like as a first person uh story game i
feel like it does have more
potential and the gameplay is always
better
among some of the other third first
person uh story games
we ain't we you know what we're gonna
talk about we're gonna talk about slime
ranchers uh
bg you yeah i know that's that that's
your that's your goat of this year and a
slime rancher
man i'm not even going to waste like my
breath on that that is not something
it's absolutely not something i care
about what about grounded is that
something that you ever tried
i'm i'm not wasting my breath on ground
did i you wouldn't catch me
you wouldn't catch me dead playing that
game we we know you love ground with
man well so am i guess it looks like
it's coming to
to consoles finally like it's kind of
weird that switch has had their hand on
this
for so long i mean i feel like it's been
on the switch for like a year at this
point
yeah but it's still not out on xbox and
playstation
yeah um i mean i even though it seems
like the among us hype died down
it's probably still a lot of people
playing it um i assume
um and i don't know if it could have a
resurgence because the thing is the game
is still
the game is still fun i would still play
it i still want to play you know
i think um but people getting the you
know just getting everybody together to
to play it sometimes i don't know i
guess feels like
feels like a chore but i still want to
play among us
like i like the the the you can have
public lobbies and they fill up pretty
fast but
like they like doing that text stuff and
i can't lie through text
like you have to convince people
that you're not full of [ __ ] and it's
hard to do through text
right so i prefer to to be to be voiced
so i'm hoping you know that they'll fix
that on consoles because like right now
it's mobile
and i think that's the main reason you
get so much text is because it's mobile
but i feel like 15 player lobbies is
good
but sometimes it was hard to get 10
people together
now they want to add another five i can
see it doing well and i'm pretty sure
when it comes to playstation and xbox
it's going to be cross play so i think i
think we'll see some
some good stuff from this man but i do
feel like
as far as like a fun game to play with
friends there there's not a lot of games
better than among us
it's definitely one of those those fun
things man i remember when you played
when uh weapon will play press start
and and kofi tried to act all smart to
vote you off early so no one will vote
him off remember that
yeah there's a lot of and you and him
were both the imposter he was trying to
throw everyone off
yeah and i was like this is a terrible
idea he got voted off like two more
turns later
yeah it was a terrible idea i hated him
after that yeah so
they actually made some really good
games uh i don't really
want to go over too many because i want
to talk about the show in general
because
i know some of these you ain't gonna
care about man like these scent you
don't care about that do you
no i actually think the ascendant is
fire oh that's a day one oh you you're
gonna try these sin
what what makes the ascent a day one for
you bg is is it because it's in game
pass or are you buying it but
no no i'm buying it as as you may know i
i've still never subscribed to game pass
um i'm not doing game fast i refuse to
uh buy that
um but no i say just looks good man it
looks
it looks fun i think it's just the
everything comes down to combat to me if
you
if the combat just looks fun and it
looks right i'll i'll buy it um and i
think what is that three player
but it's it's you could you can still
play it by yourself i'm playing that
game by myself
oh man like you got to get out of this
mentality that
if they offering you the the the chance
to play with people
take that up man don't don't get this
this mindset because
i i don't die on that hill bg these
games are designed to play with friends
i'm if you don't got friends bg then
don't play but we all know you can play
this with people we all know this
that ain't that ain't the issue i got
people to play with man but i don't
there's just something i don't like
about about playing with people like i
just
it's i just like to rely on myself
knowing that like i can go
go i could play how i want i don't got
to talk to nobody i don't got to like
coordinate with nobody
only only time i like playing with
people is is is pvp if it's not pvp i'm
not trying to like
team up to go against some like ai and
some bots did you did you play waistline
three
no i never played that that was a good
game man i i really recommend you going
back and trying that
it is a turn bait it's like a turn-based
grid-based game like x-com i don't know
if you like games like that yeah you
like x-com
i think you really like that game it's
in game pass though bg let me tell you
right
it's a game pass i don't know how you
feel about strategy games do you like
age of empires
i love age of empires that's like man i
played age of empires like extremely
seriously
um on pc when when i was younger like i
was in a
i was in a clan like an actual clan that
we had
we met up we well online of course we
had meetings we discussed strategy
like all of that stuff right it's just
you're super
you know super nerd land type stuff um
with age of the empires two
significantly i would
you'll meet up with people you'll
discuss strategy but you won't play
ascent with other people nah but like
i'll i'll play age of the empires and
we'll be in a a clan and we'll do like
two v twos um against like other
other people and like you know do clan
matches and stuff like that yeah i'll do
that
i'll definitely do that but i i never
got to i never got around to playing age
of the empire's
age of empires three though so i i
played one and two never played three
pretty sure it's in game pass
i'll be buying that all right so
this is personally my highlight of the
show the outer worlds too
i know this game isn't nowhere to be you
don't have to tell me this i know it's
probably 2023
2024 if not 2025 i think it's going to
come out soon
i think if i were a betting i would say
this would be like mid to holiday of
2023 maybe the beginning of 2024.
i know that's like two three three four
years away uh
i like it because it was unexpected was
the only time in the show that
caught me off guard now obviously i knew
the outer worlds 2 was going to be there
i
you know i heard some rumors that uh
there was a really good chance it was
going to be there but
i when this game started am i the only
one that thought this was fable
uh where uh no oh because
did you think of that because of the
like the comedic no the colorful
first area like it was like they were
sitting there
i liked the i liked how they said that
the trailer too that was a really good
trailer like a really good trailer
it was it was it was original and and
they kept it real it was very meta like
they broke the
fourth wall they were like yeah this is
just a title screen we don't have any
game play look look at the god raise be
impressed
but like yeah we we we're just like
we're announcing our game even though
it's like three years away and
just you know just know that it's like
three years away so i i like that
well what's funny is uh you know we had
the uh the people on that that make the
outer worlds the obsidian
uh on iop and we was talking to them and
uh they wouldn't tell us what game they
were making you know they're like well
we're on a new project now because they
were making the dlc
yeah but we know what they're on now
like i knew that the outer worlds too
clearly
was was up for sure but i didn't expect
an announcement this soon
and i think that's what caught me off
guard was the announcement because
i thought you know this is probably like
a next year the year after that
i didn't think that they would come out
this soon with that
but you know i really enjoyed the
original outer worlds i played a lot of
time into that game and
and especially because of fallout
i'm a huge fallout fan too but i felt
like the outer worlds
was the better fallout 4. if that makes
sense
yeah i mean i'm not a fallout fan at all
i just eyes fall out and i love the
outer worlds so
think i think you just hate all
mainstream stuff
you try to be the odd person out you try
to try to be the rebel fighting against
the people and not
not with the people i think i tend to
like the game that does it better and
not the game that doesn't first
but i get that i felt like fallout new
vegas
was which was made by obsidian and
fallout 3 they were probably
better games than the outer worlds and i
think probably the majority of that is
scale wise
like the outer worlds was clearly a
budgeted game you could tell
i i even think there's certain planets
that you can't even go to in the outer
world
uh i think so might have been it might
have just been because they were like
not necessarily you can't go there but
there was not a lot to do there
how do you feel about microsoft flight
simulator i know bond's a huge fan of
this
this literally i know why this was here
it's a big thing for this to come to
xbox i don't care
at all whatsoever yeah i mean to
really be in the flight simulator you
got to buy the whole uh
stick and panel or whatever the the
whole rig is called
which cost those things cost like two
three four hundred dollars so
like yeah i'm not making that type of
type of investment plus i don't even
like you know
i don't like simulators i don't like
flying so but i mean i get the games
i'm sure the game you know looking at it
and what for what it is it's it's really
impressive
i i just to me i know why this was there
but when i saw this is okay this this
one will get something to drink time you
know what i'm saying like
yeah it just it doesn't it doesn't
interest me but i know it's a big thing
i feel like this was the majority of
where the show went to
forza horizon 5. it looks good man i'm
not even a racer
i'm probably still not going to play it
but i can honestly say this is the first
time
forza has been put on there where i'm
like maybe i'll try it
yeah um like ford's like i said forza
looks amazing i'm not
into racing games at all um i don't like
any racing any well let me be supposed i
don't like
any racing game i'm only into cart
racers that's the only type of racers i
like
um so i never cared about gran turismo
never cared about forza i did play forza
horizon 3 because
you know it's not a simulation it's more
open world and you know it's arcade
so if i was forced to play a racing game
it would definitely be
forza horizon um and to be honest i
don't even know why they even make forza
motorsport anymore besides it being like
a visual showcase but forza horizon
itself is a visual showcase
and people clearly prefer uh
forza uh horizon now and it's like it
seems to be outpacing
forza motorsport forest is about to be
for the most part about to be up to
eight and this is at five even though it
started like way after
i think what it is is i think forza
motorsports like the game was definitely
at like a standstill it wasn't on an
upward trend so
they let them go back to the to the
board
and just like rebuild it from the ground
up so hopefully when that game comes out
i think that's going to be a next year
game
i think 2022 looking good for xbox but
we're going to get to that here in a
second
this is what they closed the game with
bg red fall how did you feel about this
closing
so i mean as far as uh cinematic uh
trailer goes um it's it was a good
cinematic trailer because
uh like i said already it should tell
you
what you're gonna do in the game and
some of the gameplay mechanics like we
learned at least one character's gonna
have
uh telekinesis and other characters
gonna have a drone it's a four player uh
you know co-op shooting shooting game
one's the same
yeah made made by arcane arcane always
put likes these
puts like supernatural powers in in
their game
um so yeah i i'm i'm glad we learned
at least learned what the game was from
the uh cinematic and
you know an announcement um of course no
gameplay gameplay is always the best
though
but i feel like in terms of this game
i'm willing to give it a chance even
though there's no gameplay it is
supposed to come out next year
and for the most part i think that it's
going to come out next year
i've just personally like to me i don't
know about you bg but
i felt like it kind of didn't ruin the
show but it hurt the show because i feel
like
this wasn't a game to end the show on
you know what i'm saying like
i feel like you could have opened up
with this show
this game i think it would have been
maybe short in the trailer and open up
with this
i personally felt like they should have
ended it with the outer worlds too
because that was that was the biggest
game
on here that people didn't expect
because i think a lot of people
for the most part all this was expected
like no one really
was blown away with none of the
announcements and i think that's why a
lot of people
you know scored it a little bit lower uh
you know speaking of score what did you
give at bg i'm curious
what bg gave because you know i didn't
really
i watched in and out of weapon i don't
know if you guys gave it by
like a a a number score but what did you
give it
i mean i gave it a 6.5 and that's you
know
some people may think that's bad but
that's it's
the best conference microsoft has had in
a long time
um and it's a 6.5 not because like it's
bad it's bad or anything it's just my
type of you know
it's all about my type of game right
that's really what i judge it off of
at the end of the day i always say man
like i don't care what bg wants to buy
games for i don't care what cognito
wants the bad games for
i care what i like and to me i felt like
red fall was a good game but i
i i just personally felt like it was one
of those games that wasn't like
a wow moment you know what i'm saying
like and
you know i see solomon put in the
trailer that you know
it you can't end it because it was too
short i don't agree with that like
i the ending is something either
that's going to wow people or it's going
to be high quality gameplay
i'm okay i'm okay with red fall being
the last game they showed
because i think it's less expected
than outer worlds too i mean we know
obsidian was going to make it out of
words too
red fall we had no like we had no idea
this about this game's existence at all
so i i kind of got why they
why they did it i i get that but i went
back and i looked a lot of
reaction trailers man a lot and
the mo the biggest wow moment i saw from
everyone
was when the outer worlds 2 came out
like
that's why i personally feel like that
was the game
because when people saw red fall they
first off people were disappointed
because it didn't it didn't look like
the the game they naturally make
like arcane usually makes single-player
first-person games so
for all first of all there are people
like arcane multiplayer what's this
about
uh second off i i felt like i felt like
this was a politic thing
i felt like microsoft and bethesda
they wanted different things for e3 so
they came to the middle ground all right
we'll do them together but we'll let you
do the pacing of the show bethesda
and we'll let you end it with your game
that's how i
personally took it i mean i think this
is like
this this game is actually just an
evolution of what arcane has done i mean
they made
dishonored and then um well i'm not
going to sequential order but dishonored
then there's you know
death then there's death loop and both
of those games
so def loop is like dishonored except
with guns
that's that's really what it is right um
it's with guns it's a few different
mechanics but there's like there's still
the whole supernatural power
in in in def loop and like there's the
literal same
power from dishonored that's blank it's
blank and dishonored and they literally
put it in depth look right
and now they've just come up with a
whole bunch of other powers
um to give other characters in red fall
and just made it
what what probably was probably going to
be a first person
co-op shooter so i i think it's a just a
evolution you know of what they've
done so all right so
first off chat put your your score in
the chat i'm curious to a couple of you
in the chat scored this conference now
let's talk about the future a little bit
bg what's the future of xbox look and be
honest i want you a hundred percent
right now i i want that that that raw
and uncut without cussing because
obviously we can't cuss
on the iop channel but what is your
opinion
of seeing this event and seeing you know
the amount of games that they because
they did show
what they showed one new ip that's red
fall uh they show the out of words too
which is an
it's not a new ip but it's still
something that's drastic with their
their ips
and then they showed star field halo
that's four
uh psychonaut you consider psychonauts i
guess
i felt like they showed a lot of first
party here what do you feel
how do you feel about the xbox brand
right now
i think well right now i think it's
it's still very early for them and uh
you know in my opinion it's not a
platform and i say platform because
whether you um
look at it as xbox and pc or or what
or whatever but i don't think it's a
platform that really has much to offer
uh
right now like as in today but i think
towards the end of the year and in two
and 20 23 i say all the time x
like the xbox platform the stars are
aligning for them
in 2023 and beyond like there's they're
gonna have so many
like games launching that year so many
of like the heavy hitters that
2023 and and beyond right now it's it's
really just
it's really just technically halo and
and
and forza which we've you know seen that
combination kind of before
now do you think i know you're not a fan
of game pass but here's my thing with
this year okay
if you're not a fan of halo i can see
how this year can be
like can be kind of bad you know what
i'm saying
uh because they only got and i'm not a
fan of forza so if
if halo doesn't deliver i'm kind of
screwed you know what i'm saying but
i guess at that point you're already
pretty much in 2022 so
it's kind of irrelevant at that point
but like to me
what makes game pass so good
is they don't necessarily
if they don't have exclusives going out
at that time they give their demographic
their consumers something to play i mean
all these games for the most part it's
in game pass like and a lot of them are
coming out this year
so you'll have something to play like
and and i've always said it
exclusives are extremely important but
you know what i feel is it more
important than exclusives bg value
if you give people the option to play
these games at a very minimum cost and
they have the
the ability to play these games i feel
like they're going to value that more
than exclusives now that's not everybody
but it's kind of hard to complain ain't
nothing to play when you come in and you
can play stuff like
back for blood in october or stalker
like next month of the month after that
uh you know c thieves is at the end of
this month
it 12 minutes is in like august you know
what i'm saying like
there's a lot here to to play throughout
the year
listen if you're a fan of game pads then
yeah you got it i just i just don't look
at
i don't look at game pass as
an ex but like it's not one of the
things i consider when i look at
xbox and it's not just it's not just
game pass i don't like i don't like
playstation
now or whatever playstation subscription
service like
i don't like i just don't like gaming
subscription services so i completely
ignore them and i and i just buy all my
games so it's not something i consider i
just look at
you know what games they are offering
on on their platform you know outside of
uh
um outside of the fact that okay there's
a
there's a great value for them i just
look i just look at the games but
yeah now you i noticed you said earlier
you said 2023 and beyond i don't think
that's the case though bj i think that
this year might be a little bit
lacking in terms of first party but i
think next year and
on is solid you got red fall coming out
in summer most likely
uh you know starfield's coming out next
year so
uh you got forza uh motorsports eight
or nine or whatever number they're on
i'm not gonna play but you still got
that game coming out next year
uh this contraband game is supposed to
come out next year like
i feel like that that's a lot right
there and that's just stuff we know
like that's not including dlcs or
expansions they do
i feel like next year is going to be a
solid year for xbox and that's not even
including game pass and i feel like game
pass
is the the de facto that could get these
people
staying on do you see with what they're
doing now with you know the stalker
back for blood in their first party
lineup do you see how they can keep
people in this service for a long amount
of time
yeah i mean 27 out of 30 games they said
that they showed all of them are going
to game pass like listen man like
there's there's no debating that
like there's no debate in it it's a it's
a force
like game pass is a force like i don't i
don't like game pass but
i don't deny it all that it's a it's a
huge force like you have an e3
conference and you tell them like
practically listen
every game that you're excited for that
we're going to see it's going to gain
fast like how
how can somebody not not deny that right
um
so i i still think this year is is going
to end up being
okay for them i think next year might be
slightly better but i still think 2023
is when
oh then that's when it becomes heat
that's what the heavy hitters draw
yeah that's when they really that's when
they're real heat the real heat is 20
23. because i think in 2023
you're gonna see avowed you're gonna see
hellblade
because i don't think hellblade's coming
out next year i think that's the
beginning of
the year after that um you might see
like hot like a lot of
[Music]
it's a gamepl you see fable i think
fable can easily come out in 2023.
so like those are those are pretty heavy
hitters for 2023.
it just depends on how they come out now
i want to ask you a question pj first
off
shout out to the five dollar super chat
from oh dirty gamer that's a crazy ass
name dude but we're gonna move past that
xbox fans are xbox fans because
multiplayer in the community stop
chasing ps and nintendo then it won't be
xbox i don't care about ps or nintendo
that's cool man we're not necessarily
talking anything like that i don't know
if
anything we said triggered that kind of
response like
obviously in in this terms like i'm
about to ask bg like regardless what
happens with
xbox nintendo or my xbox nintendo or
playstation they're still in competition
with each other and they're still going
to be compared
it's like how you compare android with
iphone it's like how you compare
all the fast food places like and you
want this kind of comparison because
it forces these studios and these
developers and these publishers
to compete for your money if no one was
if no one was comparing these
then there would be no reason for them
to compete but
yeah it's great i mean like you know
with uh
xbox buying all the studios and then um
you know with
having game pass playstation is clearly
you know
finding a way to to respond and that's
gonna
you know work out better for for us
because you know like we've been
complaining or well
i've been complaining and calling
playstation now you're like yo we don't
got no multiplayer games there
there are none right and then like
then you you uh you learn about like
three or four partnerships they got
uh with with some new studios some
veterans that came from other studios
and they're creating multiplayer games
and you know that has to do
with the competition you know from xbox
so yeah
it all benefits us so what i want to end
the show with real quick
is i know there's a lot you're i think
you're one of the people do you
personally feel like
sony has to respond to all the studio
acquisitions to game pass in general
do you think that they're fine with the
direction they're going or do you think
they need to do something
to to to you know even the playing
fields because you said yourself
in 2023 they're going to draw heavy
hitters and i feel like if they don't
answer
it's going to be a scenario where
they're going to get blindsided in 2023
and beyond
do you feel like right now that maybe
they need a studio or two to you know
maybe even out that that content coming
out because
we've all said at the end of the day
what is king content
games yeah and if regardless i do feel
like there are
certain studios that that might that
uh that sony has that microsoft whatever
they do it's going to be really hard for
them to compete
in in a form of of quality
i feel like naughty dog is one of them
and i feel like saint monica is one of
them
but microsoft has very good studios but
until we see more of these games
i personally feel like they don't have a
game that has the quality of those two
studios
and i know some people are going to say
insomniac and sonic makes highly quality
games
but i don't think it is really crazy
yeah i think their output's good but as
far as like their games
i think microsoft makes on par games of
of insomniac yeah
yeah what playstation has in their
advantage right now
is you know they're like you said
they're known for that quality
right they're known for that quality and
they've gotten like a head start
as far as like you know first party game
releases like they've
you know uh spider-man and and there was
demon souls
and and ratchet and if you want to count
return as a second party or whatever
so they've released a lot more you know
exclusives whatever you know whether
you consider it if it's on pc exclusive
whatever they they've got a head start
at least three or four games and and
like
you could say microsoft's uh first kinda
comes out
with halo and forza so they got a little
bit of a head start do i think they need
to buy
buy some studios or or uh build some
studios from the from the
from the ground um i do but i don't
think
i don't think they need to do anything
like like a bethesda level thing
i don't think they need to match how
many studio
how many studios microsoft had to match
at all
but they definitely need to buy buy i
think i think if they bought let's say
listen if they if if they bought two
two within the next two years and
let's say you know they built i don't
know
two more i think i think that's fine i
don't think they have to do anything
grand
or like huge or anything like that i
don't i don't think so right now
so um i'm gonna read what slo-mo said
real quick he said only coalition
playground and obsidian release per game
with insomniac i'm gonna be honest
i think that's that's that's pretty
accurate um
we'll have to see how ninja theory does
with hellblade 2 before i can say that
they're on that level
uh i do think that quality wise they
but that is the game studios doesn't
make games that's on insomniac level
but game in general i feel like they
they make games that's on that level
like you know people people are going to
forget
what kind of impact star uh star i mean
skyrim had like because it was so long
ago it was
it's ten years ago that is the last time
they made it an elder scrolls game
now starfield's obviously out of the
elder scrolls game but
people love the core studio of bethesda
and they haven't made a game in a long
time
since fallout 4. and regardless how you
feel about you know their games being
buggy when they come out
there's a reason people keep playing
them because they're fun they're good
it's just most of the time when a
bethesda game comes out
the fun outweighs the bugs and
you know fallout 76 wasn't made by that
studio they just helped with it yeah
but that was one of the few times where
you saw there's more bugs than there was
fun
so that's what i personally feel yeah
and we know like
uh people know playstation you know
their their status
is great you know they're doing really
well you know
120 or whatever they're at ps4 sold the
ps5
is still selling at like the same pace
it will probably be better
people could actually buy them um and
even even with that of course we know
they still don't gotten like microsoft
level of money because microsoft is
is obviously much you know much better
they've got a lot of people that have
more money than mine yes
microsoft is bigger than gaming you know
sony for the most part still
mainly relies on their gaming gaming
sector because they fell off
in other sectors so like i said if they
could acquire two more studios maybe
build to
build two more and continue to leverage
uh you know the second party
partnerships that that they're doing
i think that'll that'll be fine for them
uh until because they they would have to
acquire studios at a slower at a much
slower pace
than than microsoft could so they have
to leverage the second party deals and
stuff like that
right now i want to throw a scenario to
you real quick all right
game pass is clearly not going on
playstation uh not
anytime soon if it ever does now
microsoft clearly wants it on on game
pass on playstation do you think
that there's a scenario there's any
scenario where they're forced to let
game pass on playstation
uh that playstation allows it yeah so
obviously
i'm talking about playstation i think
there is
i think like right now playstation is so
i think playstation is so petty bro look
i feel like right now bethesda is one
thing but you go out and you buy
something like sega
or you buy something like square enix
that's
especially square enix if they buy
scorings i'm saying right now within a
year after square enix's bought
game pass is on playstation because at
that point
they took their biggest card off the
board
if if so if sony can't go to to square
enix and get final fantasies exclusive
and dragon quest regardless if the next
one's gonna be exclusive or not
they're going to have to do something
like that that's a
big thing that's been keeping them on
the board right now i mean final fantasy
16
exclusive i mean clearly we can't say
it's not possible
like i do i don't think it's i don't
think it's likely but
possible like but that's not the
scenario the scenarios do you think that
kind of scenario that
that's not what the uh what i'm talking
about do you think that kind of scenario
would make them do that though
i i think i think sony is so petty they
would look at okay you they would look
at it as
as okay you bought bethesda you you you
bought
like square enix which you know it was a
hypothetical
sony would reach deep down in their soul
and come up with some type of way to
fire back other than giving into
microsoft because
they're just that petty like they're
they they their level of petty
knows no bounds they are going to find
some
way like reach deep down in the bag and
do something that we didn't think of to
fire back
i get that man i i feel like you know
because they're
i personally feel like they're coming
like so like playstation wouldn't even
let they wouldn't even let uh
uh or it was it was it was ea ea game
pass right
what does ea call it they wouldn't even
let that on playstation yeah
access they wouldn't even let that on
playstation i can't let
i can't see them allowing their direct
competitor
to do it then yeah like i honestly feel
like they are
uh trying to buy sega if they haven't
already bought sega there's just a lot
of things we're not gonna go into that
but
i don't think that would be enough to
make them bend the knee but if they
bought something like square enix
i i wouldn't it would it would be very i
i don't think it would be long at all
like because i feel like that's one of
their biggest partners if they if that
guy took off
the table i think it would be a
devastating hit to playstation
like i don't even think they could
really recover from that like
first like that that they rely so much
on square enix these days
that that is really hard for them to
bounce back from
yeah but you know that that that's
pretty much the show like
i it's like i said i don't know they're
not buying square enix that's that's
absurd
i actually think sony might buy squares
because they've been working a little
bit too buddy buddy here lee recently
you know obviously we'll have to see in
the future i wouldn't be surprised that
they buy square enix and i'm talking
about sony not
microsoft because i think sony could
could make that deal happen faster
and i think they can get that for a way
cheaper deal than microsoft could
if microsoft wanted to buy square enix
it would probably
cost them double what the damn companies
cost
yeah i mean i don't i don't believe that
sony is gonna buy anybody big
um like i'm not once again not saying
it's impossible
but if they did buy a a you know make a
big acquisition
i think capcom would make more sense
only because
uh of only because uh sony bought uh
evo and you know capcom you know the
street fighter
uh you know other even though marvel
isn't active right now they haven't made
a recent marvel game
i think it would just make more sense
because of the uh
of the uh the evo purchase that's the
only reason
yeah definitely so you know that's the
show you guys i appreciate it for coming
through man we have 170 people in here
definitely hit that like button if you
guys uh enjoyed the podcast
i will be back next week i'm going to
restructure some stuff around i
appreciate bg
for pulling up uh there was definitely a
lot of people in there man i
i didn't know i was going the same time
rand was going he usually doesn't go on
a tuesday
so like when i went live and i saw ryan
god i was like ooh
that was like all that that's
unfortunate but it is what it is man
we'll be back this this week on iop um
i'm pretty sure a lot of you know who
we're going to have on um
it's definitely i just tell you it's
random jazz we're having the xbox 2 back
on this weekend
uh so that that's a little bit of an
insight for you guys it's kind of like
our thing now to have them two on after
e3 so
we'll definitely go over stuff like that
and i appreciate everyone coming through
until next time man we'll see you next
week
all right lady y'all oh yeah
sorry bg tell them where you i i
completely forgot to let you do your
outro man i was trying to get you